Bien le bonjour petit insecte comment vas-tu ? *bruit d'une mouche*
Aujourd'hui on va s'exercer à
b**ser ces insectes qui nous
empêchent de dormir par exemple en été.
Ou même en hiver, les bonnes araignées tu sais accrochées au plafond.
Yann : tout à fait
Ça fait flipper. Tu ouvres les yeux, tu vois un gros truc comme ça, enfin, ça fait flipper.
Attends, on dirait un mauvais podcast là c'qui s'passe.
Yann : J'sais pas si vous avez déjà remarqué, mais lorsque vous vous réveillez
Moi je vais prendre, mon insecte customisé.
T'as customisé ton insecte comme on customise une voiture finalement
Exactement.
J'ai hâte de le voir
Donc le but pour qui n'a pas compris est que je trouve Yann et que je lui b**se sa grosse gueule
Ah j'ai un pchit aussi
Alors est-ce que peut-être il peut me dire ce que c'est insecte volant...
Pourquoi on parle comme ça ?
Yann (en criant) : Mais j'ne sais pas
On est trop pas naturels
Yann : Voila
Squeezie : Mais mec mais attends mais t'es énorme mon gars
Tu fais la taille de mes pieds
Yann : J'ai customisé... Mais attends qu'est-ce tu fais la?
Viens-là ! Viens-là qu'j't'attrape mon pote !
Yann : Nan, nan, nan. :|
Viens là que j'attrape !
Yann : ...Nan, nan. Attends j'te pique !
Touches pas à mes veines, mon pote. Mes veines m'appartiennent !
Mais regarde tu crains même pas les gifles !
Yann et Squeezie : AHHHHHhh !
J'tai vu spawn, j't'ai vu spawn, j'tai vu spawn, j'vais te pchiter !
Yann : J'aime pas çe bruit, J'AIME PAS CE BRUIT ! NNNAAANNN !
EH BOOM !
Yann : Merde (x854 :|)
Yann : AHHHHHH
*Musique chelou* EU AH HA !
J'ai gagné chui hyper content.
J'suis content, ça va changer ma vie, ET mon nombre de vues.
*Yann se marre* Et surtout mon nombre de vues, d'ailleurs.
Squeezie : Est-ce que tu m'laisses pimper mon insecte ?
Yann : Avec GRAND plaisir, j'dirais.
Merci Yann.
*générique de Pimp My Ride*
insecte :|
TADDDA ! Voici l'insecte que je viens de pimper, c'est une sorte de coccinelle, avec un avant de scorpion, et des ailes d'aigle.
OUUHH ! (inaudible.)
nous sommes dans un métro, je suis un microbe parmi les microbes.
Ah j'peux pas voler ?!? NANAANNNNNN !
(Yann et Squeezie parlent en même temps, c'est donc inaudible, sauf le mot "sac". )
AHAHAHHHA.
Yann : AHHH ! T'es dégueulasse, dégueulasse !
On est d'accord que... c'est la musique d'Harry Potter, ça ?
*Musique d'Harry Potter*
J'ai fait l'insecte le plus nul à chier du monde. *Yann rigole*
*Yann rigole toujours :|* ...qu'ce soit clair.
Le truc qui vient d'Australie, mais il à survécu... 24 heures :P
apparemment, il était en disparition direct.
*générique de Pimp my Insecte, la nouvelle émmision de Squeezie. :|*
Ok m'tnant, je propose, une abeille avec une tête de souris !
Cette fois, j'espère bien voler, et te percer les oreilles.
Tu viens m'chercher ?
Yann : YAAA !
*merveilleux rire de la part de Squeezie*
Yann : Y'a pt'être... Ouais, ouais, en fait ouais, tu vas t'foutre de ma gueule pendant très longtemps.
Suqeezie : Ah merde ! Non ! Tu m'as eu !
Yann : VOILA.
Attends, t'sais quoi ? J'vais t'dire, j'vais t'dire...
...J'suis pas posé dans mon jacuzzi, j'suis posé sur ma paroi en verre.
Alors Yann, on tourne en bourrique ?
*Yann se pète de rire*
*Squeezie rejoint Yann*
Ca t'plaît tout c'qui est expression d'vieux, hein ?
Parce-que toi t'es un p'tit peu vieux, Yann, rappelle-nous ton âge ?
Yann : Tien, vla.
Squeezie : OH MERDDDE !
Yann : Tiens, tiens ton âge !
*Rires*
Yann arrêtes tes conneries, j'ai ta femme en otage, Yann.
Squeezie, en criant : UN POIL DE PLUS ET J'LUI TOUCHE UN TÉTÉ !
Yann : Tiens ! Oh merde !
Squeezie : POOOOOOOOOOOOO !
Yann, j'ai ton p'tit ami en otage, ne fais pas ça, Yann !
Yann : Oh bah ça j'en fous, ca y'est, j'suis re'dvenu hétéro, j'arrête de boire du thé ! YAAAAH !
Oh vous avez vu les buveurs de thé comme Yann vous traite ? C'est scandaleux. (Moi même, P0ufi, je bois du thé =P)
Moi même j'bois des p'tits thés, j'vais pas vous mentir.
Yann : Ouah, tapette à souris !
Voila, j'lai posée, c'est génial. *Sluup* Alors... (MalaiseTV xD)
Attends, attends, attends. Ah bah j'suis con. :|
*Rires de Squeezie =P*
Yann : Nan mais attends, mais, nan nan nan !
*Yann crie*
Squeezie : Ouah j'suis tombé sur la tapette à souris !
*Squeezie rigole*
Yann : AH tu vois, j'l'avais....
...Judic, judicieusement placé en plein milieu du salon !
Squeezie : Tu l'as mis au bon endroit mon gars, vraiment !
Yann : Parce-que j'sais pas si vous avez déjà r'marqué...
*Squeezie rigole en buvant du Coca Cola*
Yann : HAHA AHAAHAHA !
Yann : Arrrgh putain j'peux pas aller dans l'autre classe !
Squeezie : Eh ben voilà j'te spamme ! Continues, continues, eh voilà !
Yann : AHHHHHH
Squeezie : Eh voila j'te slappes.
Yann : Mais c'est SUPER RESTREINT !
C'est c'qu'on appelle du spawn-kill, eh voila le p'tit dernier...
Yann : Nan (x148)
Yann : URGH, J'TE PIQUES !
Squeezie : OOOOOHHHH !!! C'est dar c'que t'as fait ! Des barres.
Yann : Oh bien ouej ! Ahhnannn !
Bon j'ai tenté un truc, Yann
J'ai tenté, ça va être moche !
Yann il est direct dans la critique ! Désabonnez-vous.
*Yann et Squeezie rigolent :P*
Squeezie : Oh il est beau celui-là, oh qu'il est beau, tu vas l'adorer !
Est-ce qu'il peut voler ? Ouaiiis ! Il vole vite en plus !
Yann : Je crois que la...
*Squeezie arrive et le pique*
Squeezie : OHH T'AS RIEN VU !
Yann : J'sais pas si t'as r'marqué, mais l'escargot, ainsi que l'escalier, sont en forme d'escargot. :|
C'est nul. :(
C'est nul a chier.
J'espère que vous vous êtes désabonnés, là y'a plus d'doute sur c'que vous d'vez faire.
Yann : Ouah mais j'sais pas si t'as déjà r'marqué, mais les escaliers en forme d'escargot, ça r'ssemble à des escargots. :|
Squeezie : J'sais pas si t'as déjà r'marqué, mais le pilote d'affichage ne répondait plus et a été récupéré. :| (R.I.P PC de Squeezie / 201(?) - 2016)
*Musique classique*
Yann : En tous cas, c'est très stable, c'est tr.. vraiment agréable.
J'sais pas si vous avez d'ja r'marqué...
*Squeezie rigole*
Ok me dit pas que ton perso n'peux pas bouger sinon j'viens chez toi et j'te b**se
*Yann* en criant : C'est bon , j'peux bouger
Squeezie qui lui répond ouverte: OK !!
"Ah non j'aurais du dire:  "Ah bah non j'peux pas bouger."
"Viens on va boire du thé alors!" :|
Squeezie (en riant) : Ah bien joué.
Où est-ce qu'il est ?
J'l'entends plus p*t*in mais... Oh il est la
*Et Squeezie s'en bat les steaks et commence a rire* *Yann le rejoint :|*
Oh OH mon dieu
Alors j'ai j'lai judicieusement placé encore une fois
Squeezie : C'est vrai ?
Le menteur de Yann dit :NON
En plein milieu d'la pièce
OH WHAT THE FUCK ? WHAT THE FUUUUUUUUUUCK
Squeezie: Arrête, c'est des bouquins, c'est du bois !
Tu vas foutre le feu à la bibli !
Yann crie : j'en ai rien à foutre !
Comment les élèves vont aller au CDI ?!
*Action nulle et ensuite le rire de Squeezie le plus chelou*
C'est un p'tit insecte qui t'pique comme ça calmement :|
J'aimerais refaire la bibliothèque mais j'aimerais te chasser comme ta mère quand t'as eu tes 18 ans
*rire* mais quoi ?
On a dit qu'on ne parlait pas d'la vie personnelle
*rire de Squeezie toujours chelou*
Tu t'es pas fait chassé t'as 18 ans mais non pas du tout toi
Toi t'étais un fils un papa, à Noël t'avais une voiture toi !
Eh voilà le jeu a craché voila ça m'apprendra
Voila parce que moi a noël j'avais une orange et j’étais bien content !
On va aller dans le saloon
Allez
Mon nom est McCree
Alors ma custom insecte
Non McCree pas McCustom
Aah très très drôle
OOOOh oui tu es mignon tu es tout mignon Yann, on dirait un petit chat
Parce que tu vas pas vite, rien du tout AAAH
Voooilà on en parle plus.
Tu es une abeille ?
Ouais
Mais sans dard.
Rien à voir avec le cendrier bien sûr.
*rire*
On en est là aujourd'hui sur la chaîne de Squeezie en 2016
Je te vois pas, t'es où ?
Et boum !
La grosse feinte dans ton c*l !
À maintenant on a une musique de desperate housewives.
Moi elle est pas facile.
Oh nonnnnnn !
Je sais pas si t'as remarqué mais quand tu crash 20 fois d'affilés après t'es un peu saoulé.
*rire*
Je peux prendre la vieille femme avec des seins absolument dégueulasses.
Alors j'aimerai que tu la prenne.
Ah mais c'est super long ça.
Merci,
Ma femme en est très contente
j'sais pas si t'as remarqué mais les vannes de beauf ça fait toujours rire
Ah j't'ai pas touché O-O
Eh bah non mais moi par contre j't'ai touché
Et j'parle pas de tes tétés
Tape ce mec voir
Hop voila *seulement Yann qui rit*
*ensuite Squeezie*
J'ai le trophée.. Pas sous ma jupe !
Non j'te jure j'ai pas envie d'aller sous ta jupe
Parce que ça fait 35 ans qu'personne n'est aller voir
Tu es convoqué au bureau du... directeur.
Yah... Oh hop la dans la teuch'
*Rire*
Oooh ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas entendu "teuch" merci !
Mamie elle à des bras de 20cm ou quoi ?
C'est un t-rex mon gars
C'est un putain de t-rex
*rires de Squeezie et Yann*
J'sais pas si t'as remarqué mais mamie elle est nulle à chier
J'vais te prouver que la grand-mère bien que peu séduisante n'est pas si nulle que tu le penses
Tiens dans la schneck
Raté t'as vu le balais il est nul hein ?
Il est nul a chier . Tu vois ces mains ces mains elles ont du vécu mon gars elles ont touché des choses tu n'as pas idée
Ça fait longtemps que t'as pas vu un dard mamie hein ! *rire maléfique de Yann*
Hooop la..
OH BOOM !
Ah elle m'a slappé ! Elle m'as slapp... Ah tiens prends ça mamie!
Ah BOOOM
Non non non non non
Ah non t'as pas du... Oh bien joué
J'sais pas si vous avez remarqué mais c'est la fin d'cette vidéo
*Rire fort*
J’espère que ça vous a plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo, comme d'habitude
N’hésitez pas a vous abonner à la chaîne de Yann c'est du bon contenu une fois par an c'est vraiment...*rire*
Abonnez-vous a la chaîne de Yann, portez vous bien, ciao tout le monde...
Tu dis pas Peace ?
Non
J'sais pas si t'as remarqué mais c’était mieux avant !
Ouh.
Sous titres réalisés par de très gentils abonné(e)s ! <3